me léger mais ce crime ce inscrite dans
un contexte d' attentat raciste
au point que ce matin à corte quelques
centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées pour dénoncer la
multiplication de ces actes racistes ou
xénophobes sur l'île de beauté
en effet depuis quelques mois cette
recrudescence de l'intolérance s'est
traduite par divers incidents aux
agressions dans les maghrébins font
souvent les frais creuse sans père ils
sont tous là pour une seule cause la
lutte contre le racisme près de 500
personnes de tous les horizons
politiques réunis ce matin à corte et
marocains
que ça plaise au corps sur le salon
n'est ce pas c'est la première fois
qu'une réunion d'une telle ampleur a
lieu en corse deux heures de débat avec
parfois quelques témoignages très
émouvants solidaires ont bien fait de me
prouver le contraire
quelques interventions virulentes peuple
corse il est comme tous les peuples du
monde il assez tard et c'est débile
profond et ces gens intelligents et
parfois des discours plus militant de
leader nationaliste qui a fui en contre
toute évidence qu'il n'y a aucune
recrudescence d'actes racistes à l'heure
actuelle en corse il y a une tradition
encore ce qui est une tradition de
tolérance est aujourd'hui ceux qui se
revendiquent de ce peuple ne peuvent
aller que dans ce sens depuis le début
de l'année on voit pourtant de plus en
plus sur les murs de corse des
inscriptions à caractère raciste
depuis janvier il ya une trentaine
d'agressions racistes dans l'île
en mars dernier à bastia pendant
plusieurs heures des jeunes s'en était
pris violemment d'autres jeunes
d'origine marocaine et la police avaient
eu toutes les peines du monde à ramener
le calme règne ici c'était et plusieurs
attentats parfois revendiqués par des
groupuscules nationalistes ont visé des
habitations appartenant des familles
d'origine marocaine ou algérienne
beaucoup d'attentes à t'entraîner
maghrébins les gens d'origine maghrébine
pasqua au bout de quarante ans en corse
je me sens corse
mais si j'ai fait à la maison ici c'est
parce que je me sens corps se sent bien
ici
ces actes racistes au sont le plus
souvent commis par des petits groupes
ultra minoritaire et la majeure partie
de la population corse souhaiteraient ne
plus voir à l'avenir ses actes et ses
attentat raciste